[Applause]
billionaire entrepreneur elon musk puts
his money where his mouth is i am
personally guaranteeing that value and
standing behind that guarantee with all
of my assets his greatest asset is his
ability to take this big big dream
and make other people believe that it's
true
the determined engineers big dreams
transformed three industries i'm just
wishing to any entities that are
listening please bless this launch you
know here's an immigrant from south
africa i come into america to say you
know
nasa that whole rocket thing you're
doing with the space shuttle i got a
better way
his better way meant risking everything
we had maybe
about a week's worth of cash in the bank
or less i had to make a choice then that
either took all of the capital that i
had left from the sale of paypal to ebay
and invest that in tesla or tesla would
die
others weren't so willing to take a
chance on him or his companies you put
90 billion dollars
like 50 years worth of breaks into into
solar and wind to solyndra and fisker
and tesla and enter one i mean i had a
friend who said you don't just pick the
winners and losers you pick the losers
it's very unlikely that the tesla
investment is ever repaid to the
taxpayers electric vehicles
are
really not possible in ways that would
be effective for most consumers still
but his bets have paid off we didn't
just repay the principal we actually
repaid it with interest and a bonus
payment so ultimately the
u.s taxpayer actually made a profit of
over 20 million dollars on this loan
elon musk has even bigger dreams that
might just take him farther than anyone
else elon musk goes a step further
earth's not big enough with spacex he
literally wants to go to mars a long
time i'd really love to go to mars and
that's the overarching goal of spacex
[Music]
when i was a little kid i was really
scared of the dog
but then i i sort of came to understand
okay well dark just means really the
absence of photons in the visible
wavelength 400 to 700 nanometers
it's hard to believe that entrepreneur
elon musk was ever afraid of anything
and elon said darkness is merely the
absence of light then i thought well
it's really silly to be uh afraid of
a lack of photons
then i wasn't afraid of the dark anymore
after that
once one of the kids said to him look at
the moon it's a billion miles away and
he said well no it's actually under 250
000 miles away and they said oh elon
entrepreneur elon musk has spent his
life proving people wrong growing up in
south africa musk was the oldest of
three children and started school a year
early his father was an engineer his
mother mae was a model and nutritionist
he was the youngest he made about two
days and the shortest and then he was
this brilliant boy and so people didn't
really like him so i was
this little bookwormy kid and probably a
bit of a smile alec so
this is a recipe for disaster not that
he told me much about it but he was
picked on quite a bit so just like read
a lot of books and uh and traced out
people's way during school and so his
social life was much less than my other
two kids and that's a typical nerd
i read all the comics i could buy or
that they let me read the book store
before chasing me away
i read everything i could get my hands
on from when i woke up to when i went to
sleep at one point i got i really ran
out of books and started reading the
encyclopedia and he has a photographic
memory so he could remember everything
anytime i had a question my daughter
tosca would say call genius boy
his brother kimball musk when elon was
10 years old he got tested by ibm
and he was found to have one of the
highest aptitudes they'd ever seen for
computer programming i tried taking some
computer classes but i was way ahead of
the teacher so it didn't really help
so i started programming the space game
called blastar
musk already thinking like an
entrepreneur figured out how to sell his
game and i don't think they realized i
was 12.
we decided we were going to open an
arcade out near near our high school we
were big into video games we figured
that it was going to be a huge hit we
got a lease on a building we got the
arcade provided to deliver the equipment
and the only thing we needed to do by
the end of it was get the city to
approve
what we were doing
but an adult had to apply for a city
permit and they hadn't told their
parents what they were up to but of
course they told us we were not going to
be opening up an arcade
max czafkin is a technology and business
journalist who has profiled elon musk
several times
really the most amazing thing about his
childhood is his escape from from south
africa
i remember thinking and saying that
america is where where great things are
possible more than any other country in
the world it's a little cliche but it's
true america is the land of opportunity
by moving musk would also avoid
mandatory service in south africa's army
growing up in a part of south africa was
pretty surreal i mean we didn't support
that government we didn't believe in it
and so the idea of actually going to the
military service was really out of the
question
i told my parents i was going to to
canada and they tried to convince me not
to leave
and off he flew and i thought wow he's
so independent of course as soon as he
lands he calls me and he says what do i
do now
so i bought it by saying from montreal
to vancouver and that allowed me to kind
of see
canada at least from the highway he
worked at odd jobs across the country
before settling at queen's college in
toronto in fact when i went to college i
rarely went to class i just read the
textbook and then showed up for exams
the big appeals university was being
able to date girls my own age actually
met my first wife there
musk got an engineering and business
degree from the university of
pennsylvania and a scholarship to go to
stanford
silicon valley was the promised land
i really wanted to just kind of go where
where the really exciting
breakthroughs were occurring elon had
this ability to to look at the world go
this is a real problem that's going to
happen
in 20 years he looked around and he saw
that the world changing stuff was not
happening at stanford
i didn't even go to class i called the
chair of the department and said i'd
like to try starting this internet
company
it probably won't succeed and so when it
fails i want to make sure that i can
still come back
my kids do
funny things and i'm never too concerned
about them because you know if elon
wanted to drop out of college he could
always go back my brother was in canada
at the time and i said look i think we
should try to create an internet company
so he came down and joined me he had you
know two thousand dollars
no friends uh
barely enough money for an apartment i
think he told me he was showering at the
gym because they didn't have a shower
where he was living we just got some
a few times that there were couches
during the day and then turned into beds
at night
steve jervison is a venture capitalist
in silicon valley i first met elon and
kimblemusk his brother back in the mid
90s when they first set foot in
california i think they'd been here for
about a week and they were pitching a
new company called zip2
silicon valley in the mid 90s and late
90s was a gold rush people were flocking
to the region to find riches to make it
in the internet business musk came up
with an idea to bring newspapers into
the digital age he took a cd-rom yellow
pages some mapping software wrote a
little code and put it all together to
create the first online city listings
elon was more the the business
mastermind i was more the sales guy i
still had my my core programming skills
so i was able to write the the software
needed for for the first company now
when elon was starting zip2 keep in mind
you know the internet was just a couple
of years old
most local businesses were not on the
internet and the way you found a local
business was you opened up the yellow
pages the thought was the media
companies like the newspapers are going
to need help coming online and building
lots of functionality into their
websites we had someone literally throw
a yellow pages book at us and tell us do
you think you'll ever replace this and
we thought the guy was crazy
because
not only were we going to replace this
but that's not where it ended it would
keep going from there
it wasn't long before media companies
across the country were signing up
and so we were able to
get as investors and customers the new
york times company hearst night ritter
and a number of other
companies in 1999 the alta vista
division of compact bought zip2 for 307
million dollars in cash and 34 million
in stock options musk was just 28 years
old i thought that's crazy why would
somebody pay such a huge amount of money
for this little company that we have it
actually obviously turned out very well
for them financially so that they knew a
lot more about it than i did when the
kids sold them to it was the most
exciting day we couldn't believe it
because you don't know in the internet
world if you're going to
you know make a million or die tomorrow
[Music]